la starac Caroline vous avez été comme
moi vous regardiez la starac ah ben j'ai
regardé au tout début à la grande époque
grand ou c'est ça aussi à Jean PASC
Jennifer qu'on a eu il y a pas longtemps
de SC la star ça ça ça ça ça vous parle
j'ai travaillé pour eux c'est pas vrai
vous avez bossé pour la starac mais
quand c'est drôle au début pendant
l'émission c'était 2 an je crois prère
quelques années après d'accord quelques
années après d'accord ok on sécurisit le
le château et on a dû
sécuriser différentes personnalités li à
la SAR d'accord pendant l'émission ou
après l'émission pendant l'émission il
il y a une personne qui a été menacée de
mort ah d'accord ok donc la production a
pris des chos au sérieux candidat
candidat ouais c'est ça présentateur non
voilà ne peut rien dire la ST c'est ça
[Musique]
évidemment
on était tous fan et on est encore fan
la SARA qui revient donc à partir de
novembre sur dis c'est coupé
court la fête est finie comp
bon donc le 4 novembre donc ça revient
sur sur TF1 un moile et il y avait une
conférence de presse ce matin où ils ont
tout annoncé alors il y en a a des prof
qui se sont fait virer il y a des petits
nouveaux les candidats on sait pas
encore
exactement qui a été dévoilé quoi
d'autre encore le château là aussi y a
du changement ça va durer longtemps
racontez-nous un petit peu 12 semaines
c'est ça une douzaine de semaines euh
plus de 3 mois de Château contre 6
semaines l'année dernière c'était un
test un peu l'année dernière parce y
avait le foot il y avait le foot
absolument et là ils sont dit ça
fonctionne bien ils font jusqu'à 40 %
sur les cibles commerciales et là il
vont il va y avoir 16 candidats 16
élèves parmi des milliers de
candidatures trié sur le volet le mot
d'ordre du producteur tu vas me le
confirmer c'est l'authenticité et ce qui
a conduit au succès de la starac l'année
dernière c'est la typologie du casting
ça peut être mon petit frère ma grande
sœur et pas des stéréotypes de
téléréalité alors nous on est tous
exclus bien sûr parce que c'est 18 25
ans bah non pas du tout pourquoi tu dis
ça chante vraiment ça chante vraiment
très bien Michel Goldman revient donc là
pour le coup pour les gens c'était
important directeur des châteaux et et
en fait il y aura évidemment des guest
nationales et internationales mais ils
s'en foutent un peu parce qu'en fait le
produit c'est vraiment les candidats et
les al moi ce qui est important c'est
qu'ils vont fêter et Noël et le jour de
l'an mais elle nous l'avait dit Alexia
souvenez-vous quand elle est venue
Alexia la rbert quand elle est venue
dans dans PAF il y a un mois elle nous
avait fait elle nous avait confié cette
information il nont passé Noël dans le
château parce que ça va durer quoi 3
mois plus de 3 mois c'est ça plus 3 mois
et pour la première fois il va y avoir
une quotidienne 7 jours sur 7 en plus du
live intégral sur Internet qui a
d'ailleurs fait monter les les
abonnements de myf Max donc on va les
suivre comme dans une fiction c'est une
fiction du réel sauf que ce sont des
vrais personnages et ce qui est cool
avec la starac c'est qu'on les voit
progresser de A à Z d'A ça ch vraiment
très bien c'est peut-être le seul
reproche qu'on pourrait faire a priori
c'est qu'on se dit B il y en a ils ont
c'est déjà des produits finis quoi c'est
ça oua ça marche tellement bien qu'ils
vont ouvrir une boutique en ligne ils
vont faire une tournée comme à la grande
époque une grande tournée à travers les
HES de France début 2024 avec une
dizaine de de candidats qui auront été
sélectionnés et en plus de ça pour créer
l'événement signalisation ils vont tout
simplement faire des soirées thématiques
tous les prime seront thématisé la
soirée de Noël la soirée d'Halloween la
soirée de sélection des candidats pour
la tournée et il faisit ça déjà un peu
mais c'est quoi une boutique en ligne
ils mont vendre des mugs exactement des
meugs des casquettes il y a une vraie
effervescence autour du format de la St
et il y a plus Yanis Marchall alors on y
vient on y vient donc voilà ce qu'on
disait effectivement il y a des départs
a des petits nouveaux bah oui Yan Mar il
était sû de rester quand même l'année
dernière je me souv c'est vrai attendeaz
il était dans tes
PMP extrait j'adore est-ce que vous avez
parfois senti des petites jalousies de
vos collègues
non non le mot non jalousie non parce
que déjà on est tous très différents
pour être très honnête et je vais être
vraiment honnête je pense qu'il y avait
même pas essayé de faire une petite
compétition avec moi j'étais déjà trop
loin dès le départ et trop sûr de moi
donc je pense qu'ils sont calmés dès le
départ en disant bon elle on a un point
commun tous les
[Applaudissements]
de bon Mar elle a raison sopie non mais
il éta il était assez sûr de lui au
départ et et puis il avait il avait
surtout il avait dit voilà ils pourront
pas refaire une deuxième saison sans
moin et puis finalement il a été évincé
comme comme leur ballon aussi moi j'
aexpression
scénique pourquoi il s'en et pourquoi il
s'en va Yan Maral vous avez posé la
question s les raisons officielles et
les raisons officieuses les raisons
officielles c'est comme dans toute école
le corps professional il change et puis
parfois il faut savoir apporter des
nouveaux personnages pour recréerou mais
ça c'est la langue de bois donc ça c'est
la version A et la version B version il
y a des questions de planning oui alors
ou le ballon clairement elle paye le
fait d'avoir d'avoir été au cœur d'une
petite polémique moi personnellement je
trouve ça injuste j'aurais bien aimé la
revoir et et moi cette année si je peux
exprimer un jugement il y a beaucoup de
femmes on sent que la parité la parité à
joué à joué à plein moi j'aurais bien
aimé revoir l'or honnêtement c'était une
forte personnalité mais qui é mais
pourquoi plus elle y est plus parce que
tu évoques une polémique qui a eu avec
un élève elle était un peu fort à un
moment donné tous les réseaux sociaux se
sont emballés ils ont essayé de
minimiser les choses et je crois que ça
été la goutte d'eau qui a fait déborder
le comme d'habitude on sort une phrase
on la monte en épingle et on la crucifie
et
doncou moi j'ai trouvé qu' qu'elle
devrait être là il y a beaucoup de
femmes écoute on verra bien he mais
comme quoi on a vraiment changer
d'époque parce qu'à l'époque je me
rappelle André manouquin qui sortait des
petites horreurs sur la Nouvelle Star et
ça passait crème et là effectivement
leur ballon qui enfin c'était elle a
fait une petite sortie voilà elle s'en
excusé elle a dit bon je suis allé un
peu trop loin à la fois c'était quand
même un personnage je trouve emblé de la
star comme Yanis je pense que c'est une
erreur Mo d' Yanis pourquoi il part on a
vu effectivement il très forte
personnalité est-ce qu'il part vraiment
c'est question SOP qui part ou est-ce
qu'on le fait partir est-ce que en tout
cas il est remplacé par une certaine
Malica Ben jelun qui est prof de danse
déjà prof de hip hop elle a un sacré
parcours elle a chorégraphié des show
avec avec Roby William entre autres donc
elle connaît bien et on les a vu parler
et ça passe plutôt bien elles sont très
télégéniques et il y a une sais pas
pourquoi Yan s il est difficile à gérer
savoir pouroi non est parti oui à mon
avis il est pas parti à mon avis ah il
est pas parti si tu veux dire qu'il est
plus là on le fait partir il pas été REC
il était trop difficile à gérer
peut-être mais c'est vrai de toute façon
oui il était difficile à gérer mais en
même temps pardon mais il était
absolument intraitable sur les questions
de correction de comportement d'horaire
et tout ce qui est quand même la base de
la S alors c'est vrai qu'on est dessus
parce que là je vais être très franche
hein ça a duré longtemps au bout d'un
moment j'étais gagn par l'usure moi
après ils ont manqué dynamisme dans de
presse r ce que je trouve je surveille
du coin de l'œil NIOS parce qu'il faut
lui faire des piqures d'opo hein parce
qu'il va se taper les enregistrements de
The Voice kids qui commencent là là
energy Music Awards il a pas
complètement récupéré de son accident de
l'année dernière quand il est tombé de 2
m il va se taper le la chanson de
l'année la chanson secrète de l'année
plusieurs émissions et il va se taper
donc les 3 mois de la starac et après il
va se taper de Boys qui va commencer
quand ça la starac va se TER après il a
sur les prime time de la star academmy
sur la quotidienne aujourd'hui c'éit un
touton image avec la VO de Karim ouais
qui elle ass sura tout et qui sera
devant l'écran avec Nicos exactement et
notamment le mercredi où elle va
annoncer en direct les fameuses
nominations que les téléspectateurs
attendent avec impati ouais donc il faut
monter la sauce là le CH été changé
nouvelle déco 61 caméras et une nouvelle
salle une salle la salle du public
c'estàdire que pour la première fois les
élèves vont pouvoir parler aux
téléspectateurs à leurs fans être en
contact avec eux et créer finalement une
sorte de lien intime avec eux ouis
incroyable ça va fonctionner ça parce
que là ils envoient vraiment des des
gros moyens c'est effectivement
viilleette acad qui a qui a cartonné il
la densifie ben clairement l'année
dernière c'était une période d'cès et
les ves d'ailleurs le considéré bien
comme tel parce qu'il y a des artistes
ils ont tout ils ont il ils l'ont plus
ou moins admis il y a des artistes qui
qui attendaient de voir ce que ça allait
donner cette d'ailles on VO la saison 10
37 de téléspectateurs en moyenne alors
pour les primes et alors qu'on était à 7
mli2 pour pour la première saison mais
cé un
événement la consommation a
changé al ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on assiste à ce qu'on
appelle une plateformisation des
contenus avec les Netflix tout ça alors
aujourd'hui ils vont essayer de
retravailler les écriture de manière à
ce que ça soit feuillenant al bien sûr
avec 16 candidats on va pas pouvoir se
focaliser sur tous les 16 candidats donc
il y aura des des focus par rapport à ce
qui va se passer sur le château tirer un
peu la corde et puis créer une véritable
histoire qu'est-ce que vous avez appris
d'autre de cette conférence de
presse gr grosso modo c'était vraiment
effectivement le merchandising pour
employer un mot que je déteste la la le
gros gros gros barnom ça n'est pas
nécessairement péjoratif d'ailleurs tout
tout va être fait pour qu'on en parle
tout le temps tout le temps que ce soit
en linéaire ou que ce soit les réseaux
et repartent au studio 217 c'est là où
tout a commencé avec la star academmie
il multiplie par de la taille du plateau
2000 m² des écrans géants plus de 1000
spectateurs pourront assister en live
donc c'est comme comme un concert ouis
si si TF1 mais autant de moyens comme tu
dis a le grand barnom comme à l'époque
la grande époque de TF1 c'est que
vraiment ils y croient quoi il y a un
moment
donné croire parce que l'année dernière
prouvé que c à qui à qui il parle c'està
dire à notre public
jeous je puis les jeun le public féminin
moins de 50 ans en masse mais sur les de
T ou en plus ils ont eu raison de
laisser un petit lapse de temps avant de
relancer le format dans la mesure où il
y a toute une nouvelle génération qui
suivent les mamans les les les les
jeunes filles les adolescentes qui
regardaient starac à l'époque le
regardent aujourd'hui avec leurs fill ou
leurs garçons c'est ça qui est génial je
pense que ça touche toutes les
générations moi je suis plus de voice
mais je reconnais que c'est je reconnais
que c'est
malin c'est qu'on a pas le temps de
s'attacher aux personnes et ça va très
vite c'est c'est c'est un casting très
instantané là ce sont des comme des
personnages de fiction on va s'attacher
à eux voir leur parcours leurs doutes
leurs craintes leur joie leur défaites
et c'est les faiblesse parce que par
exemple moi honnêtement j'avais
totalement oublié la gagnante de de
l'année dernière c'est pas
nécessairement le gagnant qui fait la
plus brillante carrière ouais donc ça
c'est sû effectivement et mais il y a
quoi à la fin il gagne toujours un
contrat avec une maisum mais c'est ça
personnages qui vont nous plaire ou pas
oui alors non non mais ils sont mal
beaucoup d'imag tous les chiffres qui
qui s'affichent sur votre écran il des
personnages qui vont nous
prennent a les coach vocal Luc
berdardeny et Marline Schaf qui
reviennent un peu en force le coach de
sport va avoir un nouveau rôle il sera
plus dans l'autorité le relais entre les
élèves et les professeurs donc tous les
caractères sont un peu amplifiés cette
année mais quand tu dis il chante super
bien vous avez entendu des voix du coup
voilà alors on a vu un cudoscope d'image
ils sont malin il montre pas tout il
montre un caloscope
jees garçons et des jeunes filles qui
chantai vraiment très bien il y aura des
casseroles mais c'est vrai que déjà
l'année dernière ça chantait vraiment
pas pour elle les casseroles pour le
cass des casseroles qui voilà pour
pouvoir donner un petit peu de de vie au
programme bon merci beaucoup merci à
tous merci Caroline Henri merci AR de
d'être venu dans paf on se retrouve
demain c'est cyile Anouna à tout de
suite